the valley's first mega resort in a
decade has been established circa is the
first
brand new destination downtown in 40
years now and it opens tonight at
midnight it's on the corner of fremont
street
and maine it is absolutely beautiful and
we have team coverage for you this
morning hector mejia
is live inside giving us a tour but
let's go back out to john who is hanging
out by the pool hey john
good morning to you alex yes we are here
at stadium swim where it is completely
freezing now it's not freezing it's cold
though this is where look at the pools
here uh there are
what six or so pools cabanas as far as
the eye can see
a fully stocked bar and as you can see
maybe uh
down right by the front of the of the
property here you can see there is still
work being done here they're putting the
finishing touches on the property which
opens as you mentioned
at midnight tonight this is stadium swim
a beautiful part
of this enormous and brand new downtown
resort it is as you mentioned alex the
first ground-up resort in downtown las
vegas in 40 years
the last was the sundance here in
downtown that opened back in 1980.
now if you remember back then there were
some alleged mob ties back then a
controversy over skimming the gathering
license was suspended
the sundance was sold became the
fitzgeralds in 1987
and then in 2012 there were some new
owners of the fitzgeralds
but the new owners have a familiar name
now it's derrick stevens
he put 22 million dollars into the
fitzgeralds turned it into the d
a tribute to his hometown and of course
derek stevens is the man
behind uh circa where we are now now
where we're standing is one of the more
impressive parts of circa it is the
rooftop
pool the stadium of swim here are the
details six pools
six different levels 30 cabanas space
for
4 000 people again everyone's spaced out
because of covent of course
the pools are temperature control and i
can vouch for that it's like a furnace
they're really warm right now
and they can be used year round there's
also the 140 foot video screen you saw
before there's a dj booth
swim up bars it's all going to be
available for you when it opens here
circus also done something different
they've taken the kind of stodgy old
parking garage and they've made it
something kind of interesting it's
called garage mahal
nine story parking structure it's next
to the resort of course
about a thousand spaces there'll be ride
share pickup
drop off points a climate controlled
bridge their video screens in there
and security as well so all of that is
um
just makes the garage a little bit
different there is artwork
very unique artwork inside as well
inside the circa murals
chandeliers other pieces hearkening back
to the history
of downtown las vegas the golden era
some might say
and that is highlighted by vegas vicky
the kicking cowgirl
who used to be on fremont street and now
resides back where she should belong
here in downtown but this time
indoors instead of outdoors